is there a set formula for the YouTube
algorithm should I start a separate
channel for shorts should I start a
separate channel for my video podcast or
should I keep it all on the same channel
the ideal length is as short as possible
but no shorter as long as you need for
the story but no longer so how can a
Creator get their shorts viewers to
watch their long form videos we make
this beautiful video and it's the
algorithm's job to push it in front of
as many people as possible when really
the algorithm serves the viewers
in this episode of the think media
podcast I think you're going to learn
everything you wish you knew about
YouTube but were afraid to ask
ultimately I'm going to be talking today
with a YouTube employee that's going to
be covering subjects like the algorithm
like the new multiple formats podcasts
shorts tips for all of the above as well
as things like copyright strikes fair
use the community tab we're gonna be
busting some myths this is a wide
ranging conversation and I'm excited
because our guest today is Renee Ritchie
who is not just a YouTube expert himself
a current YouTube employee but also a
YouTuber himself with over 328
000 subscribers making videos about
technology and what it means for culture
and our lives and is YouTube liaison on
Twitter is actually part of multiple
Twitter accounts multiple YouTube
channels and so we are going to dive
deep today with about 642 questions that
I've written down many from our
community and so Renee welcome to the
podcast thank you so much for having me
it's great to be here so let's just dive
straight into it
um we fired off a few questions and
Katrina actually asked is there a set
formula for the YouTube algorithm a lot
of people complain that the YouTube
algorithm sucks for example people get
popular overnight versus those who've
been posting consistently really how
should we be thinking about the
algorithm yeah you know as mutual friend
Todd Beaupre likes to say when everyone
succeeds it's because of them when
everyone is in trouble is because of the
algorithm it's because of him so I think
that's just like as creators that's just
our coping mechanism and I totally
totally get that but I think like the
best way to look at the YouTube
algorithm is all the algorithm tries to
do is to understand the audience and
audience behaviors so it wants to see
like which videos of the audience
enjoying and part of that is competitive
it's like if we both make videos the
audience they have agency they get to
choose they can click on your video or
my video they have limited time and
attention and if they watch your video
for longer than my video and maybe watch
another one of your videos afterwards
your video is going to do better than my
video and the algorithm is going to
understand that it's going to understand
videos that you watch so it starts to
understand what that video is videos
people who watch videos similar to you
but haven't seen that video yet and then
it's going to rank that based on things
like satisfaction and personalized set
of rankings based on like what you enjoy
what you interacted with in the past and
it's going to decide which of those
videos to show you and if you think
about it YouTube doesn't push videos for
creators it pulls videos for viewers I
think as creators that's always hard to
wrap our heads around we think we make
this beautiful video and it's the
algorithm's job to push it in front of
as many people as possible when really
the algorithm serves the viewers and
when they come to YouTube it fills their
phone or it fills their computer screen
with you know at first maybe up to eight
different videos and which one are you
gonna click on you know your video might
be in the bottom right and they see like
a Marquez video or a Jimmy video or a
Michelle carre video or maybe they see
your video and they click on that I got
that impression I didn't get that click
so I think that's the thing that would
be helpful for creators to understand
yeah highlighting some quotes
don't think about the algorithm think
about the audience and a better question
than why did the algorithm not like this
video is why didn't my audience or wider
audience I want to reach like this video
so replace audience or replace algorithm
with audience question about
multi-formats YouTube has been adding a
lot of cool things lately of course
we've seen that there's videos and now
on our Channel homepages we have videos
separated out by live streams in the
past then we added shorts and now that's
a whole other tab now we've added
podcasts and then if you keep going
there's about there's the community tab
so how should creators be thinking in a
multi-format world and many the big
question here is creators are wondering
should I start a separate channel for
for shorts should I start a separate
second channel for my video podcast or
should I keep it all on the same channel
yeah I think YouTube right now it's all
about options like these formats of
videos exist and YouTube is hugely
popular now for short form videos 50
billion short form views a day I think
is what we said in in December but also
for podcasts there's just an enormous
community and appetite for podcasts and
we want to give viewers like the content
that they want to watch and we want to
help creators we want to enable creators
to create that content for them and we
don't want to artificially create limits
so if we can put shorts on the same
channel if you can put podcasts on the
same channel that might be the best
decision for your audience now it's
going to vary we like to say in
General's terms same audience same
channel different audience different
Channel but if you think the same people
who love your long form are going to
love your shorts and are going to love
your podcast we want you to be able to
do that so we added things like being
able to turn a playlist into a podcast
separating out episodic analytics so
that you can better understand how the
podcast is performing giving you all
those tools but it's also like Brian
Cranston can be in Malcolm in the Middle
and in Breaking Bad but if that was one
show it'd be really confusing for the
audience so you have to sort of think of
just because you're one creator doesn't
mean everything should be on one channel
it should be more like flip it around
and think like a viewer and what would
the viewer best understand on that
channel or best enjoy if you were to
start a podcast on your Channel at Renee
Ritchie where you're talking about
technology would you keep it on the same
channel I would if that podcast like for
example if I was gonna go every week and
go through all the news like the top
news on Tech meme I would do it there or
if I had a guest that was deeply like if
I had Marquez on one week iJustine on
the next week I would absolutely keep it
on the same channel if I was doing
something like adjacent to it where it
wasn't like I didn't think anybody who
watched my regular videos would also
want to watch those videos or especially
if it was like one or two steps adjacent
like I was doing something about movies
or I just don't I don't confuse my
audience for me my audience is there for
the topic and I want to make sure they
they get the topic that they expect on
that channel great and are you uploading
both shorts and regular long-form videos
on your channel I'm playing around with
it on the YouTube channels I'm doing a
lot of shorts and a lot of long form on
my personal Channel I've experimented
with long form I really like sorry
expenditure Sports I really like reply
with shorts I want to start leaning into
that a lot more because I love the idea
of conversational YouTube where I see a
comment I hit the button I record a
short it's in line with the comments and
it's in the feed because there are whole
channels now where people are just
having conversations with their comments
and I think that that's a really new and
intriguing sort of meta for video so
quickly to find that what is reply with
shorts so if you if you have a long form
video a live video or a short form video
and you get comments on that video you
can go to the reply section and on the
right on mobile there'll be a little
shorts button and you tap that and it'll
let you either record or upload a short
that responds to that comment almost
like back in the day of like reactions
like responding videos and it'll also
put a sticker with the comment on it so
if anyone Taps that sticker it'll take
them back to the original video in the
original comment so it's a nice way to
sort of because before I think shorts
over indexed on Discovery under indexed
on community almost the opposite of live
where live was great for Community but
not so great for Discovery and this sort
of adds that whole Community aspect into
shorts and so I would imagine you could
just kind of go raw off the cuff and
record a video up to 60 seconds
responding but if you're replying with a
short you also could build it out five
ten seconds at a time add in some
examples and actually craft a quality
short because it not only is replying to
that comment it's also in the feed and
so it could be kind of a jump off point
for inspiration and a short that again
rather than just one Sixty Second
recording you may show some b-roll in
there cut back and forth shoot you could
probably add music I mean it's it's the
proper short Creator correct yeah and
we've seen like whole channels of this
now especially like move like fandom
channels where someone gives a hot take
on the movie someone comments on that
they respond to the comments someone
comments on that response and you have a
whole chain of shorts going on that is
very powerful do you have tips for
creators that want to do video
podcasting specifically and what is kind
of the opportunity now the big podcast
announcement has been made your if you
categorize a podcast it can be on
YouTube music I believe that's in the US
right now and so there's the YouTube
music opportunity there's the specific
features there's a couple
discoverability things that YouTube has
been saying so what what should we be
thinking about as far as podcasting on
YouTube any kind of best practices or
just the opportunity that's coming down
the line yeah I think in general like it
just give you the opportunity to have
your podcast served in audio form and in
video form and we've seen like there's a
huge market now a huge appetite for
video I don't think it's exactly the
same as shorter form video where someone
might lean in and want to watch every
second I think it's going to be more
ambient where people are like watching a
little bit working you know vacuuming
around the house working out something
like that but there does create a human
connection when you can see the people
and you look at them in their eyes and
they're talking to each other they have
some graphics up it just makes it uh a
more understandable experience for some
people so I think if you're even if
you're concentrating on audio think a
little bit about the visual medium and
how you're explaining it in general for
videos like craft the experience that
you want the viewers to have I think
that's it's always worth your time to
just think out again think like a viewer
I'm watching this what experience would
I enjoy and then try to give them that
we're talking about multi-format we've
touched on podcasts and now back on
shorts a lot of questions coming in
about okay I've been posting shorts my
shorts are maybe getting a lot of views
but they're not translating to my long
form videos so how can a Creator get
their shorts viewers to watch their long
form videos yeah so I think the first
big question is is that what you really
want you know and then it might be that
there are only there are people who only
watch shorts and there are people who
only watch certain uh topics on shorts
like I will watch a short about dancing
but I'm not going to watch a 12-minute
VOD on dancing like a long form video on
dancing and then you have people who
watch both so I think like if you want
to tap into that shorts first audience
which tends to be very young very on the
go it might be worthwhile engaging with
shorts even if they're not like a a
billboard for your long form content if
you really want to use shorts as a way
to promote your long form uh when we
first launched shorts uh taught a spoken
about this before we sort sort of didn't
think it all the way through and people
started watching shorts and then we
thought they liked under one minute
videos we started recommending a ton of
one minute long long form videos for
them and that was just could not go on
so we split the watch history in half
and so for a while the watch history and
the recommendations for shorts and for
long form were completely separate now
what we're doing is going back and
building what we're calling these
Bridges like different lanes and these
Bridges so if someone does watch your
shorts we're now more likely to record
and they also watch long form because
some people again just watch shorts but
if they do watch shorts and they also
engage with long form we'll be more
likely to recommend long form videos
from creators that they're enjoying from
shorts I think that's just the beginning
of ways we've also put a live Avatar now
on shorts so if you see if you're
watching a short and there's like a ring
around it you can tap that and go meal
into the person's lives so you can it's
like a timely notification for that so
we want to keep Building Bridges between
all of those formats what's the ideal
and best percentage people should be
shooting for when it comes to viewed
versus swiped away and I don't know if
you're able to disclose but how is View
versus swiped away even calculated
considering some shorts could be three
seconds some shorts could be 58 seconds
that's a feature now we could see inside
of our analytics which is viewed versus
swiped away and obviously not swiping
away from our videos is better we want
that percentage as high as possible
any advice there or information so um
that's one of the reasons we don't
actually disclose what of like what a
time how much a time a view is whether
it's like for a short or auto play
because we it might change depending on
the conditions between depending on how
the products evolve and also we don't
know anyone to game the system let me
just make shorts that are only engaging
for that length of time but in general
we want like intentionality we want to
make sure the person intends to watch
the short it's basically like are you
clicking with your intention instead of
with your your uh tap or your click on a
on a computer and then this was a stat
that we have CTR click-through rate on
long form video and that basically means
we show a bunch of Impressions what
percentage of those Impressions that
people actually click on and start
watching for a long enough amount of
time that that view counted and there's
no impressions in a short speed we just
do views and that's confused some people
because they'll see like a short spike
in views which is really more like
Impressions so a new short comes out and
we'll test it with your audience and if
you don't have an audience yet you're a
new Creator sometimes we'll make a seed
audience for you you and then it's
competitive like how are people
responding to your short compared like
relatively compared to other shorts that
they're watching at the same time are
they watching less of it more of it
swiping faster are they looping it like
all sorts of behaviors what's the
response like viewed versus swiped away
is analogous to CTR it's just what
percentage of people who are sampling
your short are actually watching it the
same way you think about what percentage
of people who are getting impressions of
your long form are actually clicking on
it you probably won't quote magic
numbers but is there a magic number or
an ideal percentage this was a viewer
question for like average view duration
of a short for it to go viral or what
ingredients would make a short go viral
I think like part of it
um like there's never a set numbers the
same thing on long form video like as a
long-form video when it hits your core
audience the retention might be really
high because you know they love you and
they want they're more likely to watch a
high percentage of your video but then
as it starts going viral and it starts
being served to bigger and bigger
audiences those audiences are less and
less well matched just because because
the volume is getting so great but it's
such a huge amount the percentage of
people watching like three percent of a
million is so much bigger than 20 of a
thousand that you're still racking up
views and when you look at it he's like
oh like my CTR is way down my retention
is way down but my views are way up and
that's the sort of pressure that going
viral does so I think some people look
at it and say like what's the retention
rate for like a a short to go viral it's
the same sort of pressure as more and
more people see it there's more and more
people who will like watch it yes but
also swipe away so you'll see downward
pressure on that rate so I think like
you have to get a sense of how your
shorts typically perform and then
measure your new shorts against that
sort of number like when I get this many
Impressions what's my usual retention
when I get this many Impressions when I
have like a viral short and outliers are
nice because everyone loves that flat
retention line but doesn't teach you
very much where when you have like an
underperforming video or an over
performing video and you can see oh they
dropped off here or are here all these
spikes I guess that joke didn't land the
way I intended it to and that's when you
can start to get like kind of gnarly
data out of it so I think like figure
out what's a good retention for your
shorts with the average amount of views
you get and then always try to improve
that like see where it's dropping off
and like think like is there a b plot or
a joke or a beat or like a reset I can
do that will get that to continue and
compete against you more than you
compete against YouTube creators are
very encouraged because now we can
select a thumbnail for our short
when uploading from mobile at the time
of uploading do you think there will
eventually be the ability to change
thumbnails of previously posted shorts
do you have any news in regards to the
future of thumbnails for shorts like as
a Creator I feel like I want to control
every little aspect of my short
including like fully custom thumbnails
but this is proven like like a huge
discussion point with creators even some
of the biggest creators I think some
people feel that for long-form video
thumbnails have become an industry unto
themselves like they can spend days and
days and incredible amounts of money
making thumbnails like especially when
you're at the top spectacle level of
YouTube uh and there so some characters
like we don't want any part of that
there's something beautiful about just
uploading a short not having to worry
about like making a competitive
thumbnail like it doesn't show up on
that many surfaces it's like in the
short shelf in the shorts Tab and it's
one less thing I have to worry about
please don't do that to me and then some
people say well just don't use it like
but yes but then it becomes competitive
so I think like right now we're in the
stage of just collecting feedback so
like you and you know everybody
listening to this we'd love to hear
everybody's feedback on it we want to
take our time make sure we do it right
because I think worse than than not
releasing it would be releasing it like
a bad version of it so we'd love to hear
any and all feedback on like keep it
super simple or give us all the options
talking about videos long form video
standard videos
what is the ideal video length yeah I
mean that's a really interesting
question and like I don't mean this as a
cop-out at all but the ideal length is
as short as possible but no shorter as
long as you need for the story but no
longer because we're finding especially
now people have so many options not even
on YouTube not even on multi-format but
there's all these streaming services and
people can go outside again I mean
there's so much competition for
attention I think people can
increasingly tell if you're just doing
filler or like making a video longer
than it needs to be and the tolerance
levels for that are lower and you can
see that in your skip like little like
if people are starting to skip through
your videos or jumping through chapters
which I know is a little bit
controversial but you know some
sometimes chapters can show you where
people would have just abandoned your
video before but because they see
something interesting in a later chapter
they're willing to skip to that chapter
that's an indicator that maybe the video
is too long or not interesting enough to
get them to watch through so I think the
ideal length is what you have to explain
in as concise and interesting way uh as
dramatic a way as possible and then
don't pat it out any more than you have
to because people get getting more and
more sensitive to that on your personal
Channel where you're talking about
technology do you have a Target or is it
just random based on trying to make the
video as concise but if the story takes
a while then you'll go longer is there
any video length you personally Target
I've been testing things like recently I
went through like I went through a phase
of like my Hayden Hillier Smith phase
where I just like over edited like
everything and a little bit of like the
Mario juice like like you know Jimmy
retention editor phase where I was like
cutting everything so it'd be maximum
attention and then because I had left
less time now that I'm working at
YouTube I went through a phase where it
was like Charlie penguin Z Ludwig
mobilemail no editing like I'm just
gonna talk I'm gonna just like
extemporaneously and that's the
beautiful thing about YouTube is that we
do have like these incredibly tightly
edited like Jimmy or Eric videos where
there's not a second that hasn't been
considered and they get millions and
millions of views and then you have
Charlie and Ludwig uploading like three
times a day and the video gets a million
views and they do all it is like a
little white iPod like iPhone head
pot and people are just interested in
what they have to say so I think like I
personally like to experiment I think
shorter is better that's where I'm
leading but I would encourage anybody to
figure out like what their style is what
Their audience Vibes with and aim for
that what is the best upload schedule
for YouTube yeah so this goes right back
to uh replace it with the audience so
what is the best upload schedule for
your audience and if your audience does
care about when you upload then you
should care about when you upload and
that can be things like breaking news
where they expect you to have timely
coverage you know some channels put up
three four five videos a day of breaking
news and that has a shelf life and so
it's very important to get that up
almost immediately time of day doesn't
matter as much but the timeliness really
matters and then you have channels like
Mark Rober once a month you know Nile
red I think like two or three times a
year maybe and they get Untold millions
of views and it's like sciencey and they
have a very disconnected different
expectation so I think like figure out
what of course like figure out what's
best for your own well-being like you
your family everything that's important
to you and then one of the cool things I
tried is I did I did one video two
videos three videos four videos a week
uh for a while and then I did uh videos
published compared to average views per
viewer and I could see where people were
hungry for more and the more videos I
published they started watching more and
then as I got towards four I could see
that they're starting to choose between
them like they were coming to YouTube
and seeing two videos or they're like I
only had time to watch one and that was
like the law of diminishing returns
hidden immediately if my views are
dropping over time what's going on whose
fault is it and what should I do so
there's a couple things like I always
believe like there are certainly times
when like they're like bugs or there are
things that go wrong or like like the
world's most brilliant video doesn't get
the views that it deserves but again
going back to it being a competitive
market is it could be a lot of things I
always like to feel empowered so I want
to think like I have a lot of control
over this so for example what I see
frequently almost most frequently I
think is people just say My Views are
down everyone I'm talking to as their
views are down YouTube must have changed
the algorithm which is not really how
the algorithm works it kind of evolves
it doesn't really change change that
much so you go into analytics and you
look and most of the time you'll see a
huge Spike video like one video just
smashed it was incredible it's a huge
Spike and then that video dropped at
some point and after it dropped the
views went back to about maybe a little
higher than normal but about what it was
before that video and people see that
reflected in their analytics as minus
views or like My Views are down when
really it's that one outliner video and
then the people whose views aren't down
don't respond to them but the people who
also have a similar thing will say yes
yes me too and they think that oh
something must have changed but there's
a lot of value in just looking inside
analytics and seeing not just like
what's happening on the month the go to
the year and see if there are any of
those big spikes and from a 30 000 foot
Google YouTube level is seasonality
platform wide something that is real or
is it just I mean in one country certain
things could be up like on a macro level
is there waves of seasonality in terms
of consumption yeah I think so like
globally it's probably harder to measure
because like you have northern and
southern hemisphere and people have
different schedules but for a long time
I think we've talked about when people
go back to school there tends to be a
change in in viewership just be like
they go back to like they go to high
school they go to college where people
tended to mostly watch throughout the
week during summer vacation they go back
to watching more on weekends than they
do during the week that doesn't mean you
have to publish on weekends it's like if
somebody makes you a sandwich while
you're napping and you wake up and
you're hungry you're still gonna eat
that sandwich so you don't have to
overthink it but there tends to be
people more people watching uh like
throughout the week in the summer in in
North America and then more on weekends
because they're busy at school or work
and sometimes that also changes their
viewing habits like they're they watch
different types of videos depending on
like whether it's like a sports season
and they enjoy they watch more Sports
content if like if like a new political
season is ramping up they might watch
more political content if it's like
September and all the big Tech all the
new phones are coming out they might
watch more Tech content in September so
I think there's a lot of seasonality
that goes around we're recording this on
June 5th 2023 and right now when I look
at when your viewers are on YouTube the
interesting thing using the sandwich
analogy we're making the sandwiches
throughout the week we don't really
upload on Sunday we usually schedule a
short for the days we don't upload but
right now shockingly enough Sunday
starting at 7 A.M is the time when it's
the darkest purple inside of my YouTube
analytics starting at 7 A.M Pacific
Standard Time Of course our local time
there is a five hour block when almost
you know it says very many of your
viewers are on YouTube and it's darker
purple than any other day of the week
obviously we're speaking to an exact
moment and I'm just asking for your
personal opinion main thing is maybe why
would that happen which just happens to
be June people are watching obviously on
Sunday but would you recommend in light
of that data that we are thoughtful
about a proper upload
at that time or does it not matter and
we shouldn't overthink it yeah I think
that is more just how to calibrate your
own expectations so if you upload in the
middle of the night your views are the
acceleration on your views is going to
be lower because there's less people
around to watch it so if you see a lower
number than you expect in analytics like
wow this video is not taking off oh it's
the middle of the night there's not a
lot of people around to watch it but if
you saw that in prime time like oh
there's a problem with this video I need
to change this thumbnail immediately
because people are around to watch it
and they're choosing not to watch it I
think those sorts of things we want to
give you as much context around it as
possible you can decide that my
personality is I need to see instant
results so I'm going to look at this and
see when people are up and give them the
video then or it could be I don't like
analytics I don't care what it is I'm
gonna put it up whenever and it's just
I'm letting this bird free in the sky
and that's all I'm going to care about
we just want to give you the information
to help you decide make all those
decisions for yourself so we've talked
about videos and podcasts and shorts but
there was recent news Google is killing
or has already killed YouTube stories
why is that and what is the future we
started investing so much into shorts
and into Community posts and just
putting more and more features in there
and it became clear there was an overlap
and there's always only so many hours in
the day like even when you have these
huge companies there's so many Engineers
so many hours so many days and the
question became like where what's the
best place to invest that energy and
stories started to feel a little bit
duplicative and a little bit limited
compared to what we could do if we
invested more into Community posts for
example we have evaporating Community
posts now we're working with stickers
and Community posts we're really
building them out to be more robust and
they can they can support a much wider
range of content than stories could at
the same time shorts give you a much
better like palette for video and they
give you like features like reply with a
short remix all these things that you
could add to stories but then again
you're just duplicating features so I
think we chose rather than have like
these three things that we're splitting
attention on we're going to focus on
these two elements of them and give them
as much attention as possible so
speaking of the community tab why do I
sometimes get new subscribers from from
my community tab posts I think it's
because something resonates with them
like subscribe subscriptions are
interesting they mean different things
to different people like some people
especially old school People Like Us
who've been on YouTube Forever it's like
no this is my feed I want this channel
in my feed I'm pressing that button
therefore it's in my feed but I think
for some people now it's like that was
an amazing video subscribe is like a
super like or like a super you know
hands up or it's like I have this set of
videos that I just want to be able to go
back and reference because I'm learning
a new hobby like I'm getting into
woodworking so I'm going to subscribe to
all these woodworking channels so when
I'm ready to learn woodworking I go
there and they're all collected for me
and then like a year later they don't
care about woodworking anymore so like
it serves all these different purposes
and some people probably come through
Community posts and they like what you
posted there they discover your channel
that way and they find that interesting
and so they subscribe because they don't
want to lose track of you so to be clear
Community posts can be seen by
unsubscribed channels well of course
they could be seen if they were sought
out but can they actually have a form of
discoverability and I'm speaking to my
analytics where it'll give me Community
tab analytics will show up and it'll say
it's not super significant but sometimes
it'll be 18 new subscribers gained from
community that means that there is some
kind of potential distribution to
non-subscribed channels or maybe
somebody that's never seen think media
before is that true or false I'm not 100
sure that I can find that out for you I
do think there is some element of
discoverability I don't know how much or
where and what surface is but it's also
always possible that if it's a very low
number it's just people who unsubscribe
and then re-subscribed or you know
something else like they fat fingered it
while they were looking at your at your
channel and corrected that is there an
ideal amount of community tab posts a
day or a limit is every day too much is
three times a day too much
what are your thoughts I think like in
terms of notifications I think that we
we notify like once once a day something
like that it might be once every couple
of days uh notifications that we can
discuss how important they are in a it's
just like in a world where everyone is
so busy now again it comes down to your
audience like some channels want to be
totally engaged with their audience
Their audience expects that it's like a
very chat-based Community they want to
be there every day uh they land on the
community post they want to interact
with you and they might you know gobble
up two or three posts a day other people
might just other channels other topics
they might not be that interested or
maybe you haven't nurtured it as much so
it's one of those things where again I
would experiment like if you haven't
done them at all start with doing one or
two a week and if you see people are
really engaging with them add like a
poll add like a a quiz try the different
formats out and see what really works
well for your audience our notifications
relevant in a world where everyone is so
busy yeah so I mean like a lot of these
I think a lot of these things are when
creators feel like oh my video didn't
get as many views as it could be my
subscribers told me they didn't see it
uh they claim they didn't get a
notification and one of the nice things
about YouTube is that we have all this
data so you can go in and you can see
see how many people have turned on
notifications and set the Bell to all
and like for my channel it's 14 but then
right under that I can see that six
percent of those people then turned off
notifications for the app so for
whatever reason they're like they notify
they put on notifications for all these
channels at some point they're like
either it was annoying to them or they
just needed to break they just turned
off notifications for the app which
means they'll never see those so even
though they have them on never going to
see it and then I go down to traffic
sources and I see like one percent of
people have clicked on them and to me
that just means that they're probably
out they're busy notification comes in
tells them I have a video but they're
not going to click on it because they're
doing a bunch of other stuff but when
they come back they'll open up YouTube
and that video will be on their home
screen and they'll watch it from there
because that's where the traffic source
is telling me they're watching it from
even like on the on the smartphone level
it seems like every year they're you
know apple or Google's announcing
deliver quietly or stack notifications
or mute notifications or do not disturb
modes because I think like people are
just dealing with a huge volume of this
and we forget to think like viewers like
yes they have notification not everyone
should get my notification but they have
a hundred or a thousand channels they
subscribe to and it's just not it's not
manageable talking about copyright and
fair use
so AI is a huge Trend and
um there's the movement of what people
would call faceless channels some people
making videos describe that they created
a channel that's maybe using b-roll
which is legitimate to use perhaps clips
from fair use content it may or may not
qualify for that they're using
royalty-free music they're maybe using
an AI voice over
and they're almost they're leveraging
all kinds of different software and
tools and so using their creativity to
put content together can an AI Channel
actually qualify for monetization I know
that's a loose quotes around an AI
Channel but a channel an AI voice over
and yeah can that qualify for
monetization yeah I honestly don't know
at this point I think that's such a new
question it's such a new thing and we
know like from the past not every human
generated channel has qualified for
monetization and I don't know if this
will be this is one of those things
where you hear Sundar pichai or Neil
Mohan or the heads of other big Tech
companies talk about in Microsoft site
in Adela talk about like do we need to
identify AI challenging should there be
a big generated label on anything that's
coming in Via AI how do we deal with
this how do we deal with likeness rights
how do we deal with performance rights
all of these questions I'm not a legal
expert so I don't know about any of that
kind of stuff and I do see AI as a tool
I mean like back in my day we were
airbrushing things and then now you have
like CAD programs and you have Photoshop
and then you have like 3D brush program
so these are all tools that can make any
artist better and I'm guessing it's
going to be honest on a spectrum from
people who make breathtaking generated
art that just comes from the depth of
the human soul and other people have
like an automated machine that's
stamping it out like like soda crackers
and they'll probably be like some Lion
in between but I have no idea where
that's going to be yet it's just way too
new now listen that was just part one of
my conversation with Renee Ritchie so
make sure you're subscribed so that you
don't miss part two and if you got value
out of the episode it means the world if
you like rate and review wherever you
listen to the think media podcast check
out the show notes for links to
everything we talked about including
Renee's channels and the YouTube Creator
Insider Channel and I'll see you in the
next episode